♪
>> Greg: THE WHITE HOUSE MAKES
MORE EXCUSES FOR THEIR FAILURE
ON THE BABY FORMULA SHORTAGE AS
PARENTS ACROSS AMERICA STRUGGLE
TO FEED THEIR INFANTS
TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY
PETE BUTTIGIEG IS TAKEN THE
DON'T BLAME US ROUTE.
>> THE ADMINISTRATION ACTED FROM
DAY ONE AFTER THE RECALL TAKING
STEPS LIKE CREATING MORE
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE WIC PROGRAM
TO DO THE AVAILABILITY AND THE
STATES.
THE GOVERNMENT DOES NOT MAKE
BABY FORMULA NOR SHOULD IT.
COMPANIES MAKE FORMULA AND WERE
THOSE COMPANIES, A COMPANY WHICH
SEEMS TO HAVE 40% MARKET SHARE
MESSED UP.
IT IS UNABLE TO CONFIRM THAT A
PLANT, A MAJOR PLANT IS SAFE AND
FREE OF CONTAMINATION.
>> Greg: AND THE
ADMINISTRATION CONTRADICTING
WHAT PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN JUST
SAID IT WHEN THEY FIRST LEARNED
OF THE PROBLEM.
>> President Biden: IF WE
MOVED AS QUICKLY AS THE PROBLEM
BECAME APPARENT TO US.
>> WE HAVE BEEN MOVING AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN.
>> WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
SINCE WE LEARNED ABOUT THIS BACK
IN FEBRUARY.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THE SHORTAGE EXISTS BECAUSE
THEY CLOSE THE FACILITY BECAUSE
OF SAFETY CONCERNS FROM THE FDA.
>> Greg: THEY HAVE ENTERED AN
AGREEMENT TO RESTART THAT CLOSE
TO BABY FORMULA PLANT IN
MICHIGAN.
THERE'S NO TIMELINE OF WHEN IT
WILL BE OPEN.
JUDGE YOU WERE TALKING DURING
THE BREAK HE WOULD NO INTEREST
AND TALK THIS.
[LAUGHS]
>> Judge Jeanine: I WAS ON THE
PROWL LOOKING FOR FORMULA
LOOKING FOR MY BABY AND I'M SO
SICK OF IT.
>> Greg: HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT
MAYOR PETE?
>> Judge Jeanine: SHE SAID
WHEN WE FIRST HEARD ABOUT THIS
IN FEBRUARY DID SHE NOT SAY
THAT?
THAT WAS A LIE.
THEY SAID WE HEARD ABOUT IT LAST
YEAR.
WE KNOW THAT IN SEPTEMBER,
OCTOBER WAS WHEN THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER CALLED AND THE
FDA HEARD ABOUT IT THEY SAID
OCTOBER THEY DECIDED TO SHOW UP
IN DECEMBER OR TO MAKE AN
AGREEMENT TO GO IN JANUARY THE
GOING FEBRUARY THEY SHUT IT
DOWN.
THEY HELP POOR PEOPLE ACCESS THE
OTHER BRANDS THAT THEY MIGHT NOT
BE ABLE TO ACCESS.
THE BORDER PEEPER OF PEOPLE THEY
HAVE FORMULA BUT THE
MIDDLE-CLASS AT THE FORMULA.
PETE BUTTIGIEG THIS IS THE SAME
GUY WHO THEY BELIEVE ROAD TO
WORK ON A BICYCLE EXCEPT THE SUV
PULLS UP AND TAKE THE BIKE OUT
OF THE SUV AND PUTS ON HIS
HELMET AND RIDES TO WORK.
[LAUGHS]
HE IS A FOOL.
WHEN HE SAYS THAT THERE IS
NOTHING MORE URGENT I KNOW THAT
HE IS LYING HE IS LIME BECAUSE
OPENING UP THE ABBOTT PLANT
WHICH IS ONLY BEING OPENED UP IT
STILL HAS TO BE SIGNED BY A
JUDGE IS THE COUNTRY GOES CRAZY
AND GERALDO YOUR TALK ABOUT THIS
SUBURBAN WOMEN I'LL TELL YOU
WHAT.
DOLLARS FOR DOUGHNUT.
YOU'VE GOT SUBURBAN WOMEN WHO
ARE FIGHTING WITH THE TEACHERS
AND THE SCHOOL BOARDS, YOU'VE
GOT SUBURBAN WOMEN WHO CAN'T GET
MOTHERS AND GRANDMOTHERS WHO
CAN'T GET FORMULA FOR BABIES,
I'LL PUT THEM UP AGAINST THE
ABORTION WOMEN ANY DAY OF THE
WEEK.
>> Greg: CARE TO RESPOND?
>> Geraldo: I THINK IT'S
SHOCKING HOW CONSERVATIVES WILL
NOT BLAME BIG OIL FOR THE PRICE
OF GAS WHEN THEY ARE REAPING AND
RECORD PROFITS.
IF THERE IS SUCH A THING AS BIG
BABY FORMULA.
THERE ARE JUST 3 BABY FORMULA
COMPANIES.
[LAUGHS]
ABBOTT SHUT DOWN IS REAL THING.
NOW TO THE FDA UNDER HHS
SECRETARY RESPONSE QUICKLY
ENOUGH?
I DOUBT IT ONE OF THE EVER.
TO BLAME JOE BIDEN I DON'T KNOW
BLAME YOU FOR EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENS, OKAY, OKAY.
SOMEONE SCREWED THIS UP WHY
DON'T THEY IMPORT MORE BABY
FORMULA?
THAT IS A SECRET THEY COULD DO
IT TOMORROW.
SWEDEN, ANGLIN, THEY HAVE JUST A
STRICT LAWS DO LET'S IMPORT WHAT
THE HELL ARE WE WAITING FOR?
WHY IS IT THAT WERE IGNORING THE
OBVIOUS SOLUTION?
>> Dana: THE SHUTDOWN IS A
REAL THING BUT THEY KNEW ABOUT
THE SHUTDOWN MONTHS AGO SO WHY
DIDN'T THEY DO ANYTHING UNTIL
AMERICANS STARTED GOING.
HE'S LIKE IN WITNESS PROTECTION
HE'S LIKE THE ONLY CABINET
SECRETARY YOU NEVER SEE ANY DOES
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY HERE AND
FOR PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN TO NOT
ONLY SAY WELL AS IF WERE MIND
READERS, THAT'S SO INSULTING.
IF THE ADMINISTRATION COULD JUST
ONCE JUST SAY WITH DO BETTER ON
THIS AM ON TOP OF IT AND WHEN
YOU GET THIS AGREEMENT DONE.
IN THE MEANTIME I TOLD THE FDA
TO FIX THE REGULATORY THING GET
A FORMULA FROM EUROPE, GET FROM
CANADA, MOMS I HEAR YOU.
THERE'S NONE OF THAT IS ONLY
BLAMING REPUBLICANS FOR NOT
FIGHTING AGAINST BIG OIL?
THAT IS SO INSULTING TO THE
FOLKS THERE I THINK WHEN
PETE BUTTIGIEG SAID THEY WERE
ACTING FRONT SINCE DAY ONE IT
MEANS THAT IT COMPLETELY TOTALLY
FAILED.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE PEOPLE
WHO SAID OH, MY GOSH, IT'S IS A
GREAT JOB ON A SUNDAY SHOWS.
WIKI SPEAKS A LOT BETTER THAN
SOMEONE ELSE OR NOT TALK ABOUT
LATER IN THE SHOW.
BUT HE SAID NOTHING AND THEY'VE
OFFERED NOTHING TO THEM I THINK
THIS IS AN ABSOLUTELY ATROCIOUS
THING.
IT WAS THE ONE THING THAT THEY
COULD'VE GONE RIGHT.
>> Greg: IT IS KIND OF
DISTURBING JESSE HERE'S
MAYOR PETE AND HE WAS A YOUNG
DAD ON PATERNITY LEAVE AND HE
DOESN'T LACTATE AS FAR AS WE
KNOW.
[LAUGHS]
HE HAS A GOVERNMENT SHOULDN'T HE
HAVE BEEN ON TOP OF THIS?
IT'S A MUST KIND OF LIKE HE
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN THIS.
>> Jesse: HE CAN'T GET BABY
FORMULA AND JOE BIDEN'S AMERICA.
AND MAYOR PETE IS EVEN A FAN OF
JOE BIDEN SO IT'S STUPID.
LUCKILY FOR ME AND GOD JESSE JR.
IS A FOOD'S NOT BECAUSE WE WENT
THERE ABOUT 3-4 DIFFERENT BABY
FORMULAS BEFORE HE FINALLY FOUND
THE ONE HE LIKED.
HE WAS PERSNICKETY I FEEL BAD
FOR YOU AND ALL THE MOTHERS OUT
THERE BECAUSE SOMETIMES IT TAKES
A LONG TIME TO GET IT RIGHT.
PETE SAYS OF THE THEY DON'T MAKE
BABY FORMULA DOESN'T MAKE
ANYTHING.
ONE IS THAT EVER STOP THE
GOVERNMENT FROM GETTING INVOLVED
IN EVERYTHING?
[LAUGHS]
GERALDO, THE FDA HAS THROUGH
REGULATION AND OVERSIGHT WHERE
THE DEMOCRATS CONSTANTLY WHINING
ABOUT?
MORE GOVERNMENT OVERSIGHT, THE
ONE OPPORTUNITY THEY HAD TO GO
IN THERE AND DO REGULATION
EVERYONE'S LIKE THEY ABSOLUTELY
BLEW IT.
THIS IS UNLIKE OH THERE WAS AN
OUTAGE.
OKAY, OKAY BABY THE FDA, KNOW
THIS IS BABY FORMULA.
>> Geraldo: THEY MOVED UNDER A
GLACIER PACE.
>> Jesse: THEY WORK SPEEDY
GERALDO.
>> Geraldo: RELATIVELY
SPEAKING IT WAS A GLACIER PACE
WE WERE WAITING.
>> Geraldo: WHAT TOOK HIM FIVE
MONTHS GERALDO?
>> Geraldo: I MERELY SAYING TO
IGNORE THE STRUCTURE OF THE BABY
FORMULA INDUSTRY IS TO DO IT A
DISSERVICE.
>> Jesse: WASN'T JOE BIDEN
IMPORT.
IF THIS IT HAPPENED UNDER
DONALD TRUMP.
HELPING FAMILIES AND NOW HE
STARVING FAMILIES.
IMPORTED.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE CDC MADE
A DECISION THAT NOTHING AND THAT
CONTAMINATED THE BABY FORMULA
AND THEY MADE THE DECISION A
WHILE AGO SO THIS IS A BUNCH OF
FAKE GARBAGE ON THEIR PART.
JOE BIDEN AND THE OTHER ONE
SAYING THAT THEY HEARD ABOUT IT.
>> Greg: WE DEFINITELY DON'T
HAVE STRONG OPINIONS ON THIS.
ALL RIGHT, PRESSURE BUILDING